Is it good to ask for MRIs and CTs without contrast?
No, because, yeah, you can, but you can't see the same things.
So I was told that the heavy metal in the catalyticium stays in the brain, it can, it can build
up.
Where people really have problems, people have a sensitivity to it and they can have a reaction
to get really sick.
You've had it before and you don't have that the chance of that happening is pretty small.
It's a very small percent of the population that have that type of reaction.
So again, again, you go back to my bottom line of this is you only do these invasive tests
if it's going to change the way you treat.
So you don't do an invasive test like MRI with catalyticium or CT scan, which is just by itself
without contrast.
There's a lot of radiation.
You don't do that if you're just trying to satisfy curiosity.
So you only do it if it's going to change the way you're going to treat it.
And of course, for the medical doctor, stand up point, they're like, yes, it's going to
change the way I treat it because if this is positive and we see changes, then we're going
to up this dose or change this dose, I get it.
But if the patient's like, well, I can let you do that anyhow, well, then don't do it.
So you're ultimately the person has to deal with all these things.
They will go home, you know, to their families to the end of the day, you've got to deal with
the garbage that happens afterwards.
So you have to, you have to weigh those things out, okay, well, I'm not going to do any more
of that anyhow.
I'm not going to get that MRI or CT scan because even the CT scan without contrast is in tons
of radiation, it's like 50 chest x-rays.
But if you can't do the toxins, then if you can't do the, you know, with the toxins and
know that catalytic builds up on your system, that can't, that is an issue to weigh those things out.